au Pitre that depends who's asking Peter
[Music]
we are gathered here today to join B and
Thomas in holy matrimony
you're taking this so well he's a good
man you hated this guy we've grown very
close welcoming a new parent not that
close a father father father no you're
not my father
sorry are you the author it's really the
rabbit story I just wrote it down look
dad it's Peter Rabbit oh I hate that I'm
the face of this he's naughty what a new
Peter that depends who's asking Peter
told you he has it in for me he was
talking to all of us I'm talking to you
Peter
specifically stay out of trouble if
that's who they think I am maybe I'd be
better off without them
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
what are you looking at goody-goody you
gonna turn me I'm know pretty goody
apparently I'm a baddie batter I love a
is your name Peter Rabbit yeah I was
best friends with your dad
my name's Barnabas you're a fierce bad
rabbit just like where are the rabbits
back in their burrows snug as a bug in a
rug
back out spread out
[Music]
join them bullet I'm speeding up a
little I'm speeding up quite a bit and
that's why adults shouldn't do kid stuff
you